qui l'a dit je n'ai aucun atome crochu
avec Isabelle moi je sais
Daniel Moreau Isabelle il y en a
beaucoup hein
[Musique]
c'est vrai
Isabelle j'ai un peu de mal avec sa
position ouais pourquoi parce qu'on n'a
pas la même façon de de voir la vie de
voir la politique de voir la vidéo vous
étiez pas du tout aucune aucun atome
crochet à Isabelle avec elle mais ça
c'est depuis le début depuis assez
longtemps le courant ne passe pas ça
arrive on passe la oui non mais je
savais pas du tout que elle il y avait
un souci avec elle
je lui au téléphone je lui dis est-ce
que tu veux on est dans les peines
réconciliation je deviens
vraiment il m'a dit non je lui ai
répondu hein
vous vous tuez répondu à la lutte
attendez ce qu'il a dit et à vous les
avez répondu vous mais il est venu ici
qu'on avait un petit Bizzbee mais c'est
fini on s'entend très bien et vous
dites-nous ce que vous avez répondu j'ai
sur les fiches mais tu es là
tentation de réécrire l'histoire la
réalité est plus simple au cours d'un
agréable du genou sollicité par tirer et
réglé par moi avec plaisir paye tout le
temps il m'a prié de transmettre à la
direction son désir de faire du média
sur RTL j'ai transmis alors il y a la
suite un peu plus loin j'ai transmis et
de ma faute il manque grand chef de l'or
n'a pas voulu le donner suite mais je
l'aime bien mentir d'ailleurs un nouvel
épisode de Thierry c'est pas du tout ce
qu'il dit lui il dit lui en gros est-ce
qu'il est en plus long il dit que
vous parlez de beaucoup sur les gens
dans le dos vous vous c'est ce qui dit
hein foutez un petit peu la merde
voilà
mais les gens qui sont dévorés
d'ambition comme ça juste parce qu'il y
a pas une édition au téléphone
mais quelqu'un il y a des gens qui sont
dévorés d'ambition qui ne peuvent pas
admettre que ce qu'un mec qui n'en est
pas donc il voit le mal partout bah je
suis désolé
parce que toi non moi non
ici et RTL
non c'est du travail
alors j'ai très peu d'ennemis en tout
cas déclaré lui en étant il a choisi
c'est pas grave
je lui dis est-ce que tu veux est-ce que
tu veux venir te réconcilier mais dis
vraiment je te promets Isabelle une
histoire aussi de d'amour un peu dépité
[Applaudissements]
de justice il m'a jamais demandé un
petit mot sur moi aussi
ah oui c'est vrai
je pense en revanche qu'avec Mathieu je
vais essayer de déjeuner avec lui parce
que je pense que c'est quelqu'un qui est
quelqu'un de extrêmement humain et
je regrettez de vous vous êtes écharpé
complètement et je vais rétablir ça
d'accord pour lui dire voilà
Mathieu on déjeune quand tu veux
[Applaudissements]
tous les invités qu'on reçoit la semaine
d'après je dis Véronique Jannot et tout
je dis non moi ça me fait rencontrer des
gens c'est génial et c'est vrai qu'on
est il y a pas eu de souci c'est une
connerie et cela dit honnêtement je suis
tellement pas méchante que lui il a
choisi de l'aide ça me gêne pas
honnêtement tant pis hein est-ce qu'il a
demandé à être sur people pas du tout
non pas du tout
c'est lui qui était parti il est sur RMC
et RMC c'est très bien mais ça paye pas
beaucoup alors